we worried that this would happen and
it's happening covid anti-vaccine
sentiment is now bleeding over into
other vaccines and parents are
increasingly hesitant to get their kids
vaccinated against all sorts of other
things including measles and one of
those uh and and the one of the problems
with that is we are now starting to see
outbreaks exactly as predicted you might
remember back in November we talked
about uh this story CNN reported as
measles outbreak sickens more than a
dozen children in Ohio local Health
officials seek help from the CDC a
growing measles outbreak in Columbus has
sickened more than a dozen unvaccinated
children and hospitalized nine of them
look at that ratio 75 percent
hospitalization
we often forget how serious measles is
particularly in kids because vaccination
is so effective and this leads to some
parents saying whoever heard of a kid
getting measles it doesn't sound like
it's likely and it certainly doesn't
sound serious that's because of vaccines
we have a report now from
um NBC4 about how vaccine hesitancy that
has sort of spilled over from covet
vaccines into other vaccines is causing
exactly this problem take a listen to
this hey there everybody U.S childhood
vaccinations have dipped again this year
a new report from the CDC suggest what
started as a concern about the covid-19
vaccine especially in younger people is
now carrying over into other shots too
including polio diphtheria and measles
it's likely one of the reasons cluster
outbreaks of diseases such as measles
are on the rise CDC reports show last
year it was in the Twin Cities Minnesota
area currently it's in and around
Columbus Ohio in the Columbus outbreak
there are over 85 cases and can be
counting that was compared to last
week's data but over 30 of those kids
were hospitalized and most of those
cases were in unvaccinated children yeah
Dr Judy's work is a pediatrician who
told me this new report shows overall
those receiving vaccines required by
Most states is now at about 93 percent
it was at 95 percent just two years ago
before the pandemic now that 93 and 95
percent number is actually critically
important the herd immune measles is so
contagious that the herd immunity
threshold to prevent outbreaks is
considered to be 95 percent that has
dropped to 93 percent when it comes to
Children entering kindergarten with with
the required immunizations 93 when you
were below you know people think oh this
is some vague thing it's just numbers no
it has real world consequences when you
go below that herd immunity threshold
for some diseases you will start to see
outbreaks and that is exactly what is
going on and this was the fear that the
coveted anti-vaxxers who first entered
anti-vaxxerism with the covet vaccine
would bleed over into more General
opposition to child vaccinations because
the general environment starts to become
one of vaccine hesitancy and if you get
enough people in a community that are
skeptical or opposed to vaccines it can
make others in the community more likely
to say well if these three families
aren't doing it maybe I shouldn't do it
either if the health care providers if
the public health officials
aren't well prepared to deal with the
vaccine hesitancy they are going to be
under-resourced and not able to keep
those vaccine rates up and I've spoken
to a number of Pediatricians I know
friends of mine who say I get more
people than ever even in Liberal areas
people coming to me and saying you know
does my child really need all these
vaccines some of these things don't
really seem super serious or they don't
seem super common or likely that my
child would get
and the pediatricians have to explain
well that's because of the success and
effectiveness of many of these vaccines
this is a separate conversation from the
covet vaccine and unfortunately what we
expected to see happen is indeed
happening as we see
in these reports uh what we'll turn it
around I quite frankly don't know it's
pretty horrifying to be totally honest
yet another Republican has been caught
committing voter fraud a Republican's
wife has been arrested for casting
23 fraudulent votes for her husband
remember voter fraud of this kind is
very rare
but when we find it it's almost always
Republicans Insider reports that Kim
Fong Taylor was arrested and accused of
multiple counts of voter fraud
prosecutors say that she cast 23
fraudulent votes for her husband in the
2020 election her husband Jeremy Taylor
is an elected Republican there's an 11
page indictment it is wild it claims
that Kim phuong Taylor quote visited
numerous households within the
Vietnamese community in Woodbury County
she collected absentee ballots from
people who weren't there
filled them out cast the ballots herself
quote causing the casting of votes in
the names of residents who had no
knowledge of and had not consented to
the casting of their ballots Taylor is
also accused of signing voter
registration forms on behalf of
residents who were not present that's a
crime in total it is 26 counts of
providing false information three counts
of fraudulent registration and 23 counts
of fraudulent voting each charge carries
a maximum five-year prison sentence
wow the goal was to get her husband
elected I want to remind people again
and again and again and I will continue
saying this until I don't need to say it
anymore voter fraud is very rare it's
also a pretty futile strategy that is
not likely to win an election and the
potential consequences of getting caught
make it very much not worth the risk up
to five years potentially for each of
those counts she's not going to get you
know it's 50 counts total five years
she's not going to get 250 years we I
will bet any amount of money on that but
the risk reward is very much out of
balance voter fraud is a really
ineffective and inefficient way to try
to win an election because the number of
fraudulent votes
is almost always too small to actually
impact the outcome and the risk of
getting caught for voter fraud is high
now Republicans will say everybody's
getting away with voter fraud all these
Democrats are getting away with it the
truth is
there is no reason to believe that
that's the case and we've seen the
Brennan Center for justice study the
numbers the penalties for being caught
are severe it is a really bad political
strategy It's relatively easily detected
and it would be better for these people
to spend their energy on activating
voters help make the case that voters
should vote for a candidate because they
think that that candidate would actually
do good things for them I know it's like
a crazy thing to think about but that
would be a much better way to spend your
time and the last element of this is
when people get caught
it's almost always Republicans even
though Republicans claim it's Democrats
that do this now one could say David
Democrats are doing it but they're
getting away with it Republicans are
getting caught but way more Democrats do
it and get away with it well you've got
to defend that with some data why is it
that Democrats are so much smarter and
able to get away with it there is no
evidence of that whatsoever we have yet
another potential Trump criminal Scandal
on our hands Donald Trump's Saudi Arabia
payments are sparking fresh calls for a
sparking calls for a fresh investigation
writes you and Palmer for Newsweek
let's take a look at this article Donald
Trump should be investigated over the
payments he received to host the Saudi
arabia-backed live golf tour at his
Resorts according to an organization set
up by supporters of the murder
journalist Jamal khashoggi the Democracy
for the Arab world now group has called
for the doj and Congress to look into
the quote disturbing facts and
circumstances surrounding that golf tour
and ties to Trump on January 13th it was
revealed during court proceedings that
the Saudi Arabia public investment fund
that's the Sovereign wealth fund headed
by the country's Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman owns 93 percent of Live And
pays 100 of the costs Don claims this is
the first time that the full extent of
The Sovereign wealth funds ownership in
live golf has been disclosed understand
that this uh it immediately points to
money transfers from the Saudi royal
family through that Sovereign wealth
fund to Trump by virtue of paying to
host the live golf tournaments at
Trump's golf courses including
Bedminster in 2022. this potentially
relates to money laundering this
potentially relates to an influence scam
and of course all of the answers to what
we are looking for are found in
Hunter Biden's laptop right that must be
the answer no um listen in all
seriousness
we all suspected this
we all suspected that this golf
tournament and Saudi Arabia and this
goes beyond just the United States this
was a mechanism to transfer huge amounts
of money
it could be to trump it could be to
other other world leaders because there
are live golf tournaments in various
places and when we talk about Trump and
influence peddling it already is
it's beyond the pale
that Trump's Washington D.C hotel is not
the subject of more scrutiny because
during Trump's presidency that hotel was
a Nexus of massive money transfers and
emoluments that were received by Trump
world leaders looking to ingratiate
themselves with Donald Trump saying hey
well I'll stay at Trump's hotel and I'll
mention that I'm staying at Trump's
hotel that it's a it's a borderline
crime that that hasn't been further
investigated but this one was so obvious
this is so obvious Trump was criticized
for hosting a bunch of different lift
golf events at his Resorts but we didn't
understand the full scope of what is
essentially the royal family owning this
entire thing Saudi royal family controls
the Sovereign wealth fund Sovereign
wealth fund owns 93 of the golf
tournament and pays 100 of those costs
this is um the Revelation in practice
that millions of dollars dollars from
the Saudis have been going not in terms
of arms deals arms deals are bad enough
but at least they are public or
semi-public this was a subterfuge of
sorts there should be another
investigation and it is exhausting to
even keep up with this the other aspect
to the Saudi Trump connection is of
course Jared Kushner and Jared kushner's
role and connections and relationships
with these very same folks involved in
The Sovereign wealth fund are we ever
going to know the full scope I don't
believe we are
I don't know that we are ever going to
unwind everything that went on during
those insane four years but one of the
things we can do is do everything within
our power to prevent there being another
four years just like it make sure you
are subscribed on YouTube to the David
Pacman show at youtube.com the David
Pacman show we really need your help
something is happening on YouTube with
the algorithm where it's not just the
David pakman show many channels like
ours are being de-prioritized it has
been years since we have talked about
this because it has not been an issue
for years
something is happening systematically to
a half dozen channels like ours and it
seems to be algorithmic so the best
thing you can do leave a comment
like our videos and make sure that you
are indeed subscribed we're going to
take a quick break and the Friday show
rolls on right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show continues to be a
community funded program you can support
the work we do so many different ways
but the best way
the most powerful way the most direct
way continues to be to sign up at
joinpakman.com and get yourself a
membership not only will you get access
to the Daily bonus show and the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and you'll get the show
hours before everybody else and you'll
get invited to the member Town Halls we
are also soon to launch a member sound
board where you will have access to my
soundboard Clips oh the bonus show where
you want to make money money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad you will get access to the sound
board okay very very cool stuff going on
sign up at joinpakman.com let's hear
from people in the audience we are going
to take some calls because it is after
all Friday we do this via Discord
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to West Wesley from
Nashville Wesley welcome to the program
what is on your mind today my friend
David can you hear me okay yes I can
hi so I was just wondering uh where you
would currently assess our chances of
the United States defaulting on its
national debt if the Republicans uh fail
and the freedom clock is able to hold
Congress hostage enough and Congress
fails to raise the debt ceiling
extremely low I would not bet that the
U.S is going to default on its debt I
believe that Republicans are more than
willing to damage the country by holding
out on the debt ceiling debate I believe
ultimately the same thing that always
happens is going to happen the U.S will
not default on its debt and even the
freedom caucus crazies are not going to
ultimately make that happen
interesting I guess I was just wondering
because I was reading something on the
New York Times this morning uh regarding
a couple discussions about the last
major uh debt selling fight yes and how
the Democrats and the Republicans kind
of had two different takeaways as a
result and I just worry when I look at
you know the chip Roy's and Matt Gates
as if they even really understand the
implications of the brinkmanship they're
practicing and what would actually occur
if the United States was to default and
I think that makes uh I wonder if that
makes the risk so much like
significantly higher than where we
typically would assume it would be well
they don't understand it but here's the
thing even if they did they wouldn't
really care so it's one of those things
where you're completely right they don't
actually understand it but I also don't
believe that they would dramatically
change their views if all of a sudden
you explained it to them these these
people have a completely different moral
compass and framework than we do and
um I just don't think they care
I I fully fully agree thank you for
taking my call a big fan and a big
Watcher for years and years first time
caller obviously I'm a bit nervous but
hopefully this was a satisfactory call
for you and your show today more so that
more more than satisfactory Wesley I
appreciate the call
like let's thank you all right there we
go Wesley from Nashville with some very
important statements and questions let's
go next to dimitro from Ukraine also a
website member dimitro thank you so much
for your support on the website I very
much appreciate that and if you unmute
yourself I will be able to talk to you
yeah hello uh thank you for having me
pleasure uh I I I'm not going to take my
much time I just wanted to say that I'm
grateful for your position and for
support of American people to my country
you're currently in Ukraine
yeah I'm from Kiev are you I mean do you
feel safe right now
uh yeah I got used to all this stuff so
yeah I think so and when you say used to
what are you dealing with on a daily
basis
uh well it's like uh some air alerts
time to time yeah but people are going
to work people uh like trying to live
their lives you know they're not become
insane or something you know one of the
things that is incredible dimitro is the
degree to which humans adapt and
Unthinkable situations become your
everyday reality and it's simultaneously
heartbreaking but also incredibly
inspiring that that people adapt but
obviously we want things to change so
that you're not dealing with air raid
sirens on the way to work
yeah I agree people adapt and uh yeah
I'm great grateful to American people
and to be honestly I watch American
politics time to time because uh you
know a lot of stuff actually affect us
and I was nervous during this speaker
election or in Cincinnati elections so
I think everything is going to be okay I
I admire your optimism and I really
appreciate you calling in today
thank you thank you all right there is
dimitro from Ukraine why don't we go
um why don't we go next to David from
Philadelphia and see what's going on in
Philadelphia David from Philadelphia
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today
oh no we might be losing David from
Philadelphia
sir
all right well no David from
Philadelphia let's Instead try George
from Virginia George from Virginia
welcome
George from Virginia you're on
George from Virginia you almost
certainly have the wrong audio device
selected
oh there you go now you're back oh okay
sorry about that
um so uh yeah thanks for taking my call
I really enjoy your show
um I wanted to bring up something that's
kind of been bothering me lately
um if you look at like
the media and even like independent
creators in the left uh space sure I've
seen a lot of fawning over uh Pete
bootage Edge and
I wanted to ask you do you think there's
like a tendency
for people and especially the media to
kind of focus on like
the you know he does so well in
interviews like he owns uh Republican so
well but if you look at his job
performance it's I'm just not seeing it
you're saying that as Secretary of
Transportation you don't think his
performance has been good exactly yeah
so here's the thing there's two
different conversations here George
right one conversation is do we think
that in terms of image and performance
he's the type of person who could win an
election and then secondly is the
analysis of how do we evaluate his job
performance as Secretary of
Transportation on the second part I
don't have an answer in the sense that
he's been getting blamed for stuff that
really has nothing to do with him to be
totally honest including like for
example the global supply chain issues
like that's not Buddha judge's fault the
FAA thing I don't know from what I've
read it it doesn't really seem like it's
his fault but let's let me put that
aside for a sec second what I think
makes Buddha judge an interesting
potential presidential candidate is that
he has a number of characteristics that
make him a good modern presidential
candidate and what I mean by that is yes
he is very good in adversarial think on
your feet positions particularly with
bad faith right-wingers that actually
matters right now when you think about
how you become the nominee and
eventually the president number two he
has enough policy ideas in enough areas
you can talk to people to judge about
Transportation electric cars foreign
policy China education Latin America and
he's not going to get embarrassed on any
issue and he'll probably have at least
an idea to put forward on any one of
those issues that's really important he
won't come off as a buffoon on any issue
um he's well spoken you know so so do
you understand the difference between
the two analyzes that we're doing
yes yeah I I understand that so I'm just
more than willing to entertain the job
performance things you're bringing up I
think they are basically at this point
for better or worse completely divorced
from whether he would be a good
candidate it's sort of like Gavin Newsom
I'm not like a huge fan of Gavin
newsom's politics necessarily but I do
think he has an attitude that is useful
for Democrats to have when it comes to
Republicans in 2023 so he's the type of
guy who might do well in a campaign even
if he's not like the Uber Progressive or
the guy I would say this is who I would
love to see as president
yeah I I think you make a lot of valid
points um but uh just to end my uh
opinion here I just wanted to say like
I'm a little bit worried because
there's so many Americans who have been
impacted by the airline situations yeah
and if Democrats push this guy Center
Stage even if he speaks well and all
that people might be like no this guy
sucks you know he the airlines were
horrible under him and I feel like it
could sabotage the Democrats if they
choose a guy like this that's always
possible now you're making a prediction
and I'm terrible at predictions so you
may well be right it may end up being a
terrible self-sabotage or not I just
don't know
well I I really appreciate your opinion
and uh thank you very much all right
George from Virginia uh appreciate the
discussion very very much why don't we
go uh why don't we go next to
oh I don't know it's so tough to say
what about Keon from North Carolina Keon
am I saying that correctly
Keon from North Carolina please join the
chat my friend
and absolutely last chance for Keon from
North Carolina
Kian is gone very very important stuff
all right let's try Neville from
California Neville from California
welcome to the program
Neville from California I have invited
you to join folks please uh please stay
near your devices Neville welcome
Neville from California you've got to
fix your audio if you want to talk to me
my friend
Last Chance Neville you're there Neville
is gone all right let's go to Tom from
Jersey listen if there's ever been a
time to go to New Jersey for for saving
us I think it's right now Tom from
Jersey what's going on
hey David can you hear me yes I can
thank goodness
yeah I was getting where he goes like is
this like a that might be the next one
but
um
I live in Jersey which is great it's a
blue state I'm really happy with how our
state government functions but there is
one issue I have that I've also noticed
is an issue with a lot of other blue
States in fact I think that someone from
The New York Times something about this
okay New Jersey for being the most
diverse state in the country is also
school-wise one of the most segregated
and in Connecticut there's also supposed
to be liberal State it's I believe it's
the state with the largest income
disparity because you have like wealthy
people live in Stanford yep right next
to low-income people who live in Newport
I mean a new Bridgeport and New Haven
correct and Washington they have really
um really favorable corporate tax rates
for like Amazon and in California they
talk about the housing but whenever they
try to build uh multi-family or single
or affordable housing a lot of people
who live in like San Francisco or stuff
get really upset so why do you think we
keep seeing this issue of these liberal
states or people who live in these
liberal areas who I just seem to be
helping push inequality or helping or
not super for uh invested in trying to
attack systems or reform systems that
cause this type of inequality I'm not
saying that the answer is an interesting
one this has been studied so the if I
understand correctly Tom the main
question you're asking is
it's liberals and blue states that talk
about fixing income inequality yet it's
many of those very blue states that have
the most income inequality right I mean
is that more or less what you're saying
yeah basically yeah so two things on
that number one the examples you're
giving are absolutely accurate when it
comes to particularly
um Connecticut
however if you zoom out and look at the
country in total
it's only slightly worse of an issue
overall in blue versus red States the
inequality issue it is an issue so
you're you're right in your analysis but
it's only to a relatively small degree
so on average blue states are a little
more unequal than red States but not by
a huge margin but it's sort of a result
of the fact that blue states are
economically more successful and it's
basically a result of the fact that
on average blue states have higher
incomes average incomes and that is
pulled up by Blue States having more
wealthy people and that increases the
level of inequality by virtue of having
those additional wealthy people so it's
a result both of the successes of those
very policies and the fact that that is
what increases the very inequality that
these states want to fix
okay I always knew yeah I never I always
knew that we were better at it than the
red States but I always thought to
myself just because we're better than
them doesn't mean we shouldn't look into
it
absolutely and there's if you Google
liberal states and income inequality
you'll find a ton of good resources on
this it's been widely studied
yeah you know but you know I'd never
want to live in a red State I'd stay in
Jersey or New York my whole life all
right well that's you're right my friend
all right have a great day okay thank
you there's Tom from Jersey Tom is not
leaving Jersey is the message we are
getting or he'll go to New York which is
also completely fine all right let's
take a very quick break I'm taking more
calls it's just I need a very quick
break
hang on and then we'll get right back to
it
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's get
back to hearing from the most important
people in our ecosystem the audience we
do take these calls for the Friday show
we do it via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord and you can join what is called
The Waiting Lobby let's go to Alex from
Vienna now Alex is that Vienna Austria
or is it like you know Vienna Idaho or
so I don't know that Idaho really has a
Vienna but hey David thanks for taking
my call no it's Australian Vienna
Austria yeah have you called in before
no it's my first time your first time
yeah well welcome yeah so therefore I'm
a little bit nervous you're doing great
so far you've stated your name and where
you're calling from beautifully and
that's an auspicious beginning
perfect thank you so much so uh I have
an overall question
um how can we uh left procs left procs
uh improve because uh I think it was in
the United States that uh who was it
Kevin Newsom said something like that
that the leftists have to be more
um
and pop
populists
I don't remember Newsom saying more
populous would I remember Newsom saying
as Democrats on the left need to be more
ruthless we need to be unabashed we need
to you know but to to that was the gist
of his comments as I recall them
okay yeah something like that yeah and
in Austria we had a similar discussion I
mean it was six six or seven years ago
by uh Peter piltz he was from the green
party and he tried this approach and he
was a uh overall a really good
um
person who tried to um
yeah as you can hear I'm nervous sorry
um you're doing great yeah so but so is
your is your question about whether this
is a good strategy yes and how to
improve listen
we
it's in the United States Democrats
aren't really doing this yet they're not
being ruthless to use Gavin newsom's
word
so I don't know if it's a good strategy
what I can tell you Alex is the status
quo is not working very well and even
though the left is right on so many
issues we're losing the discussion on a
lot of those issues when really we
should be winning because we actually
are on the right side of the issue so
it's very plausible that changing how we
talk about these issues is a great
starting point and I like the idea of
Gavin Newsom now will it work it's a
that's a predictive statement we have to
try it and see
mm-hmm
but listen Okay what do we have to lose
at this point you know
yeah yeah for sure because uh the the
part is on the right uh you know they're
sealing the the the topics yes and and
manipulating them something like that
100 I mean we can do that as well in a
positive sense I would say yes uh and uh
and not just um being in the defense all
the time that that's the impression I've
got in my own country yeah I am with you
and I hope to visit Austria soon I was
supposed to right before the start of
the pandemic and then we all know what
happened and I would like to get back I
want to go to Vienna I'd like to go to
Salzburg I want to be all over the
country
I'm great okay yeah I might be again in
the States this year no well then I'll
miss you I guess that's too bad all
right Alex from Vienna thank you for the
call thank you thank you very very good
did an excellent job excellent job let's
go to
uh is it pronounced jaquavius jacovius
am I pronouncing that correctly
jaquavius are you with us
Jacoby is you're on but you have to
select the correct audio device
last chance for jaquavius to fix your
audio
are you there jacobius no jacobius is
gone that's too bad uh sad quite quite
sad in fact why don't we go to Nico from
Illinois Nico from Illinois welcome to
the program what is on your mind today
hello
Nico
Nico we heard you I don't know why you
muted yourself
all right there we go
uh hey David uh this is my first time
calling in and I kind of just had a
question about social media and
influencers and how they subliminally
push kind of right wing ideas
and how they kind of get these kids that
follow them to believe into these
right-wing ideas and what's an example
kind of educate them what's an example
uh just with like Andrew Tate and all
that stuff that's gone on with him I
feel like there's a lot of
um influencers out there that kind of
like support him and try to make him
seem like he's this really cool guy see
here's the thing about that Here's my
thought Nico and I this is an ongoing
conversation that we can have and I I
just I'm not sure it seems that these
types of people appeal to exactly the
same folks and what I mean by that is
you know I did this segment a few weeks
ago about
um liver King and Andrew tane and Jordan
Peterson and I didn't mean to say that
they are the same in their ideologies in
fact they are quite different but the
point was they end up pulling in
basically young men often with less
going on socially than they would like
often less relational you know less
involved in relationships than they
would like often without a defined or
successful career path yet and so they
end up being different flavors of
characters that pull in the same types
of people and I'll give you an example
I don't know anybody and I'm sure they
exist anecdotally but I don't know
anyone who works in you know has a good
job as a lawyer or as an accountant or
or you know even a success whatever and
is sitting there watching Andrew taint
videos you know what I mean it just it
seems like it's it's mostly young men
that get sucked in so while I agree with
you
that it's a bad thing that these figures
pull people into this sort of like
pseudo right wing
pull yourself up by your bootstraps type
ideology it's really only afflicting a
particular demographic group
overwhelmingly
right and I was just just because I was
just wondering this because I had seen a
report that supposedly in the UK they're
kind of like re-teaching these young
kids to try to get them away from these
like Andrew Tate effect and all that
stuff so yeah I just didn't know if that
was like a good way to go at it or if it
was just kind of like a waste of time
because at the end of the day these kids
are going to go home and just watch what
they want to watch you know that's true
and you know I know a high school
principal I was recently it's actually a
middle and high school principle and she
was telling me that she's aware of
seventh and 8th graders who watch Andrew
Tate and that's really the risk because
these these kids haven't even really
defined anything about themselves yet
and that's where it's like now that's
that seems like a particularly
pernicious age at which to be consuming
that type of nonsense
yeah exactly exactly yeah and like it's
not like
they kind of let you form your own
opinion you know they kind of just force
the stuff on you and yeah without a
doubt it's just not something that I
would want my kid to
be exposed to you know I agree I agree
well I appreciate the call
yeah thank you for taking my call Sir
all right take care there is Nico from
Illinois very important declarations I
think let's go to Jonathan from Ohio
Jonathan from Ohio welcome to the
program uh what can I do for you today
what's on your mind
oh boy Jonathan from Ohio please select
the correct audio device so that we can
hear you
and last chance for Jonathan from Ohio
um can you hear me now I can hear you
sir hello sir how are you thank you for
taking my call my pleasure um this is
more can you hear me I can hear you
okay
um this is more
um something that happened in Ohio that
I would like to make people aware of
okay
um
so apparently they defined natural gas
as a clean energy source now oh really
so in Ohio it's defined as
clean energy similar to other types of
renewable energy and I just wanted to
make people aware of that
yeah this just happened so for people
who don't know new law signed into uh
signed in by Governor Mike dewine
designates natural gas as green energy
that is absolutely insane and I guess
the point of it um you tell me Jonathan
you might know more about it it paves
the way to Fast Track drilling of oil
and gas in state parks
that's correct oh we're actually working
yeah I work in the natural gas industry
um and there is a lot of fields like in
the eastern part of the State uh that
they're trying to get to so it does it's
really bad for like climate change
obviously yeah and they're trying to set
a standard for other states to to do
this kind of thing and I just think
people should be aware of this and not
let it go down the slippery slope yeah
like burning natural gas is not green
that I hope people understand that now
Jonathan you work in an industry that
you think is bad for the environment it
sounds like
yes I mean like it's like the safety
side of it to make sure people you know
they don't leak or yeah you know events
don't occur so I'm on that side of it
but um
My Hope Is that the industry migrates to
Renewables like my company at least is
trying to do that but
I just thought it was good information
to be aware of 100 yeah I mean it's when
you when we think about renewable and
green
it is certainly not natural gas I
appreciate you bringing it to my
attention Jonathan
yeah for sure all right Jonathan from
Ohio delivering some unfortunately
depressing news let's go to Thomas from
the Bronx Thomas welcome to the program
hey David how are you I'm doing well
all right great let me just mute my uh
background work training I'm supposed to
be listening to I love it
so quick question for you and it's
probably going to start as a question
and really more turn into a a request
for you to interview some subject matter
experts in this area Okay so one person
considers myself on the left I would
love to have a magic wand and make
Bernie Sanders 30s years younger and
have passed all policies and nationalize
Pharma and energy etc etc right yeah but
a lot of the problems the the world in
general not just the US has is really
the ever going population expansion over
the past decades and centuries and
finding enough resources and jobs Etc to
support the ever-growing population so
my question is
if we wave the magic wand and everything
was nationalized and everything was
provided in Ubi Etc
um would that tend to lead towards an
explosion and expansion of longer life
expectancies with Health Care higher
birth rates of people not having to for
example have abortions because they
can't afford it and would there be you
know Playing devil's advocate here would
there be a negative to having kind of
all needs met and a super healthy
population in regards to expansion of
that population so I believe that Arthur
C Clarke explores this in the novel
childhood's end let me see if I can
yes Arthur C Clarke explores this idea
in the 1953 novel childhood's end which
was turned into a mini-series maybe it
was like Netflix or Amazon I don't
remember so it's widely explored in
science fiction the belief generally
seems to be that if those needs were met
the birth rate would naturally decline
actually people would wait longer and
choose to have fewer kids and that over
time it would actually take care of
itself now here's the other issue
related to this Thomas which is birth
rates are already going down down down
to the point where it's believed that
Earth's population is actually going to
start declining after peaking it's I
forget the exact dates but it's going to
keep increasing kind of China's worried
about that now China is expected to see
a population decline from I think 1.4 to
1.3 by 2050.
um yeah so no I don't think so I think
the I think people would live better
longer lives and would have fewer kids
and it would all fall into a new
equilibrium
okay that would be right and he said
Arthur C Clark he said that was science
fiction childhood's end Arthur C Clarke
excellent novel I recommend it to you
Thomas excellent I'd love to see if you
see a few interviews with you know uh
non-fiction
kind of talk about this and see what
they think because certainly I agree
about the the birth rate thing but of
course with advancing technology and
energy consumption and you know no you
know the population as a whole is not
going to turn vegan overnight so the
factory farming would still be an issue
so anyway
Thomas from the Bronx raising a very
important issue to cap off calls for
today I will take more calls again if I
have anything to say about it and I hope
to hear from you next time we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's get into the Friday mailbag the
now world famous Friday mailbag
technically we got one email from
Zanzibar and now it's world famous okay
let's get right into it remember you can
email info davidpackman.com you can also
contact us via a number of other means
including Facebook Twitter sometimes
YouTube comments will be featured you
never know what you're going to have but
today we start with a message from
Facebook and it is a very important
message and that message is about
President Joe Biden and the the things
that I choose to report on and this
individual says and I'm reading this as
written I want to be clear how much do
you get from Joe Biden to say that
really how much for Miss that's Miss
information really how much for Miss
information
sir please show me the respect of
addressing me as Mrs information
misinformation is extremely inform
um for our relationship please and of
course uh this idea that we are funded
by Joe Biden or George Soros or the
trilateral commission or the Illuminati
or the uh Klaus uh Klaus Schwab Gates so
who knows anyway we're funded by people
who sign up on our website and by like
YouTube ad revenue and a few advertisers
we have there's no secret there we're
very very clear about exactly how we are
funded uh next message is from Andrew
Andrew wrote in with a suggestion saying
David try some honest journalism I Am
pro vax but no longer Pro coveted shot I
understand you have to make this
political or keep it political because
you have an audience to Pander to but
please don't mistake what you do
for authentic journalism I see you David
remember I never claimed to do
journalism I claimed to do commentary
which is what I actually do the very
disturbing lack of media literacy in
this country leads to messages like this
but more importantly
pandering on the vaccine I'm I have to
say the things I'm saying because of my
audience I've been very very clear the
first vaccines seemed to prevent
infection and transmission as the virus
mutated the vaccines became less and
less effective at preventing infection
and transmission to the point where my
understanding of the latest data is that
the newest vaccines don't prevent
infection nor transmission but they are
still effective at dramatically reducing
the odds that you end up in the hospital
or dead I've never hidden that from the
audience I've been very clear
um so I don't know email someone who's
actually doing the things that you say
I'm doing I I'm getting quite bored with
it here's someone who writes in like
five to ten times a week they go by CAD
CAD wrote in and said by the by the way
right away going into their degrees uh
reeks of either dishonesty or
um some some kind of uh low self-esteem
okay
CAD writing yes I am Highly Educated
with multiple degrees and probably
smarter than some of your audience
members I love how you mock people and
how they talk because it's so
hypocritical you are the one who made me
do a deep dive and become Republican
thank you for that I contribute to
society with my job helping others I
don't read articles and then throw BS
out for an hour and a half with no pitch
a pushback you're not as smart as you
think anyway do you ever watch yourself
on your show you've got to be so smug
because your large teeth and mouse mouth
movements are so gross side Pro Prof
profile blah that's the vomit Emoji blah
who the hell would ever go out with
someone so pompous as yourself they'd
have to constantly stress from being
corrected you're so feminine and your
pronunciation is hysterical it's cringe
many think you progressives are out of
your mind and ruining what was good
about this country go watch yourself you
are one
ugly dude so before you get on a
platform and mock others look in the
mirror what work of yours should be
valued besides mocking people I guess
that's a statement not a question
um you know I used to get upset about
messages like this because someone is it
they're they're criticizing so many
things about me
and then one of the kind of uh
Awakenings I had was
I thought to myself you know I watch
lots of different things
I've never written to anyone that is the
host of any show I watch ever and if I
did
I would be embarrassed to send messages
like this because they're so bizarre and
out there and so then I imagined what
kind of person
would even send a message like this what
must their life be like where they have
either the time or the idea or the
interest of saying I'm going to go over
to my computer or pull out my phone and
write something like this to someone I
don't even know and then I realized how
sad the lives of the trolls must be
and then I stopped worrying about them I
actually kind of just feel bad now and
I've spoken to some other people about
it and and they who do what I do and
they've sort of come to a similar
position and it really is sad it really
is sad what must be going on in
someone's life
to think to write something like that to
someone else anyway let's get into some
of the more substantive stuff Andrew
from Oregon wrote in with an interesting
message he said one effective question
to ask anti-vaxxers hey David long time
Watcher love your work as covet has seen
a recent uptick and it doesn't seem like
it's going away anytime soon the debate
over preventative measures continues to
rage I've found a really effective way
to stump anti-vaxxers is to ask them
what group of experts informs your covet
views they may point to cherry-pick data
devoid of context or individuals who
share their view but never a collection
of experts there isn't a university a
hospital or scientific body of any sort
they rely on every time it seems to
promote promote provoke a moment of
self-reflection on the veracity of the
source of their information and I find
it's a great Foundation to build from
yeah this is an interesting idea because
often the the science deniers will say
ignore everything all doctors say except
this one radiologist who's commenting
about vaccines despite it being
completely outside his or her area of
expertise and the question is an
interesting one because when you say
what group of experts they often will
say well you really can't trust
immunologists now you have to trust this
one person all the other immunologists
are wrong or you can't really trust
pulmonologists because they mostly are
lying about covid but this one uh
pulmonologist has has gotten outside of
of the bubble it is a good question and
I think only with some people only with
with people who are most open to having
their views
um examined would it would it have an
impact but it is an interesting idea
because it's not about expertise it's
about finding people that already agree
with them and then saying here's who I'm
going to listen to and I've met people
personally during the pandemic who early
in the pandemic said these are the these
are the three people that you can really
trust
during the Pandemic those three people's
views have changed as informed by data
and Science and then the people who used
to go to them say they can't they're not
they're no longer trustworthy here's the
other people I now trust well it's not
that the people are less trustworthy
it's that you you no longer agree with
the things that they're saying and it is
uh it is something I see quite often PK
wrote in um sort of a tongue-in-cheek
response to that guy who called in
recently and attacked me for being
not that tall
um and PK wrote in about David's height
and weight says Dear David I am five
eight and weigh 165. that obviously
gives me a 15 pound intellectual
advantage over you I'm sorry sir but
that's just the science thank you for
your time yes and obviously this
individual outweighs Me by 15 pounds but
it's 15 pounds of brain matter certainly
I have to make a correction and I'm glad
Catherine from the UK is helping me do
that I wrongly stated the other day
in passing and as a complete joke that
the coleslaw at KFC is vegan
um Catherine wrote in and said hey David
watching the video about bolsonaro in
Florida and was Keen when you mentioned
the coleslaw from KFC being vegan I'm in
the UK where the slaw is not vegan so I
had a look it's not vegan in the U.S
either unfortunately it's vegan in
Canada I understand though perhaps there
is hope for the rest of the world okay
uh yeah I don't know I don't really know
anything about KFC coleslaw I remembered
that producer Pat once told me the KFC
coleslaw was vegan Pat has no
recollection of that so I don't really
know where I got it but I don't go to
KFC and I'm also not vegan so it ended
up being sort of a sort of a moot point
I guess we would say Oliver wrote in
about the phenomenon of they Oliver says
hey David have you noticed that many
especially on the right are increasingly
using the term they to Define political
opposition for example they want to
silence us they want to sexualize
children they are the Elite is this just
a symptom of seemingly populist rhetoric
with those on the other side thrown into
the one basket I.E the elite with no
room for substance or does it boil down
to something else entirely that's Ali
from Scotland I don't think they know
what they mean you know I've had
conversations where they'll they they
I'm doing it too it's it is an
interesting shorthand
right Wingers who call me let me be
precise Sometimes some right-wingers who
call me will say
they are
not allowing us to investigate the
origins of covid and I'll say who is
they
uh is it Democrats and they'll go well
no it's not really Democrats no is it
the media is the media preventing
anybody from no it's not really the
media is it I don't know like is it
marxists because that's enough an often
used Trope no it's not Mark and then you
see they don't even know who they is so
as a rhetorical technique I do think it
can sometimes be useful to say to those
with whom you are speaking
who is they exactly it's not Biden
it's not Hunter
it's not fouchy it's not uh you know
Anderson Cooper who is it exactly and
some of them are Slicker and they will
be more prepared and they'll say
something like I I say they because it's
the establishment it's no one person but
it's the total atmosphere created by the
oh okay all right uh but it's a good
question who do you what do you mean by
they I think it is a it's a useful
technique email in info davidpackman.com
and please come on over to the bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you can get instant access and it's an
extra show every single day for our
website members you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now at joinpacking.com
foreign